when I was leaving Ramon someone on that
Friday morning I'm taking my seven half
of the company out with me he said
you'll never succeed without me and I
think he gave me the Freitas let me tell
you thank God he said that to me because
when I heard those words I thought to
myself watch me I'd rather die and let
me tell you something that was my
insurance policy for success and I know
that's an attitude shift and maybe not
even from a good place I probably need a
good shift to get over could shrink to
get over myself but that shift in my gut
gave me power and so wherever you get
your power you know it's amazing I meet
so many of my entrepreneurs I'm always
looking for the magic sauce before I put
my money in them and very often the
recurring magic sauce is they have
something to prove and many proving an
insult is not true
so I love an entrepreneur that has
something to prove